it's pleasure to be here in this
beautiful city and part of this
prestigious proceeding I'm going to talk
about the future of intelligence where
we're going to enhance our natural
biological intelligence which we've been
doing through education through
artificial intelligence and first I want
to share a surprising discovery I made
in 1981 I was trying to figure out how
to tie my inventions and I started with
the common wisdom that you cannot
predict the future but I thought if I
plotted a lot of data being an engineer
visualize it in the right way I could
make some educated guesses and I made a
surprising discovery there's one aspect
of the future that's remarkably
predictable and that is that the price
performance and capacity not of
everything and not of every technology
but of information technology proceeds
in a predictable manner and I had the
price performance of computing
calculations per second per constant
dollar from the 1890 M our consensus
through 1980 in 1981 it was a very
smooth curve and I projected it out to
2050 we're now 34 years later in 2015
and it's exactly where it should be and
that predictable trajectory is
exponential meaning every fixed period
of time if it doubles it's about every
year and that and even that speed is
speeding up and exponential growth is
actually very different than our
intuition if you wonder why do we have a
brain it is to make predictions about
the future so we could predict the
consequences of our actions the
consequences of inaction
but those built-in predictors are linear
you know we track an animal in the field
10,000 years ago we didn't expect it to
speed up we expect it to go a constant
trajectory that's a linear projection
that worked very well that became
hardwired in our brains the reality of
information technologies is progresses
by doubling every period so what's the
difference the linear projection that's
our intuition goes 1 2 3 an exponential
projection that's the reality of
information technology goes 1 2 4
doesn't sound that different but by the
time you get to step 30 the linear
projection our intuition is
30 the exponential projection is at a
billion that SEP 14 said at rlly n' and
this is not an idle speculation about
the future I mean this little computer
is actually several billion times more
powerful per dollar than the computer I
used when I went to MIT in the 1960s and
we're going to do that again the next 25
years it'll be another several billion
times more powerful and so shrinking in
size this is a hundred thousand times
smaller than that computer and the 2030s
will have computers and all robotic
devices the size of blood cells so let
me show you just what this means an
exponential starts out very slowly and
then it explodes when it gets to what I
call the knee of the curve
here's that graph I had in the nineteen
1981 I had it through 1980 this goes
through 2010 that's a very smooth
exponential progression it actually
doubly exponential this is a logarithmic
graph as you go up the graph we're
multiplying by actually every level is
100,000 times greater than the level
below it so this goes back to the 1890
census this is literally billions of
times actually actually a trillion times
greater computation that we can get for
the same cause since the 1890 census now
people look at this and they go ah
Moore's law but this started decades
before Gordon Moore was even born
Moore's law is just that part on the
right having to do with chips
we were shrinking vacuum tubes in the
1950s to keep this going then that hit a
wall we couldn't shrink vacuum tubes
anymore and keep the vacuum in 1959 so
we went to the fourth paradigm people
have been talking about the end of
Moore's law which will happen by 2020
then it will go to the sixth paradigm
which is three-dimensional computing
that's already begun that'll be in full
swing by 2020 that'll keep this going
for a very long time but really what's
the most interesting thing about this
graph the fact that it's trillions times
more computational the same cost is
interesting but more interesting is
where is world war one world war two the
grow the Cold War the Great Depression
if this goes through thick and thin
through worn piece or bloom times and
recessions people said well a muscle
slowdown
the recent recession that's not the case
it has a mind of its own I have a
mathematical treatment of why this is
the case in my book singularity is near
but really the empirical evidence is the
most convincing and it's so Moore's law
is really just one paradigm among many
within computation and computation is
just one type of information technology
and I don't have time to dwell on all
this but you could buy one transistor
for $1 1968 you can buy 10 billion for
$1 today they're actually better because
they're smaller so the electrons have
less distance to travel
so they've sped up the cost of a
transistor cycle has come down by half
every year that's a 50 percent deflation
rate so this is really an economic
thesis having to do with the economics
of abundance which is what information
technology presents versus the economics
of scarcity where we see inflation
people say okay that has to do with
these strange little devices that we
carry around but you know that's just a
very small part of the economy but one
industry one area after another is going
to be transformed from a non information
technology to becoming the information
technology the one that's undergoing
that transformation right now is biology
the enabling factor for that was the
genome project that was a perfect
exponential halfway through the project
we sequence 1% of the genome and
mainstream critics said I told you this
wasn't going to work here you are seven
years one percent it's going to take
seven hundred years just like we said
that's linear thinking my reaction at
the time was oh we finished 1% we're
almost done
because 1% is only seven doublings for
100% indeed it kept doubling seven years
later was finished that has continued
since the end of the genome project that
first general cost a billion dollars
we're now down to a few thousand dollars
per genome and it's not just sequencing
our ability to understand this basically
software which is what it is to model it
to simulate it and to reprogram it to
change it to overcome disease and aging
processes is also accelerating in an
exponential pace these technologies are
now a thousand times more powerful than
they were
when the genome project was completed
now people worry about deflation we had
massive deflation during the worldwide
Depression of the 1930s there was a
different reason collapse of consumer
confidence but the concern is if I can
get the same stuff the same computation
the same communication the same genetic
sequencing that I could get a year ago
for half the price ok I'll buy more but
am I going to double my consumption
after all how much do I need are not
going to saturate my ability to consume
these resources and if I don't double my
consumption the size of the economy not
as measured in bits bytes and base pairs
but its measured in constant dollars or
Euros or Crona is going to shrink for a
variety of good reasons that would be a
bad thing but that's actually not what
we see I mean this is bits of memory
shipped we have dozens of graphs like
this we actually more than double our
consumption and we've been doing that in
every form of information technology for
the last 50 years and the reason for
that is innovation creativity basically
what the Nobel Prize celebrates when
price performance reaches certain points
whole new applications explode this is
communications internet data traffic
that's the number of bits we move around
wirelessly in the world it was Morse
code over AM radio century ago now it's
3 our 4G networks again perfect
exponential growth multiplied by
trillion in the last century this is the
graph I had at the Internet in the early
80s it was called the ARPANET connected
a few thousand scientists I did the math
and said wow this is going to be a world
wide web connecting hundreds of millions
of people in the late 1990s and we'll
need search engines because we won't be
able to find anything and the
computational communication resources
needed for search engine will emerge
what I could not predict is that it
would be these couple of kids in the
Stanford dormitory who would take over
the world of search among the 50
projects that were trying to do that but
the fact that we would need and search
engines and that would be feasible was
predictable that's the same graph seen
on a linear scale that's how we
experienced it so to the casual observer
it looked like whoa world wide web new
thing
came out of nowhere but you could see it
coming if you looked at the exponential
progression I mentioned biology this is
a whole revolution health and medicine
used to be a linear process hit or miss
now we're actually treating the software
of life as software as an information
process and so it's an information
technology and this is a grand
transformation which is generally
overlooked when we look at the future of
medicine so super computers on
artificial intelligence we need both the
hardware and the software
they've been many different ways to
estimate how much hard work capacity we
need in order to functionally simulate
the human brain Hans Moravec did in one
way I've done it a couple of other ways
it's been other estimates they all come
out to ten to the fourteenth
calculations per second we seeded that
in ten years ago and supercomputers were
now vastly beyond that a personal
computer will achieve that level in the
early 2020s so and again this is a
logarithmic scale perfect exponential
growth in supercomputer capacity this is
a whole different area but we're
applying nanotechnology which is a form
of information technology to the design
of solar collection panels also energy
storage the amount of solar energy is
doubling every two years again a perfect
exponential right now we're only six
doublings from 100% which point we'll be
using one part in 10,000 of the sunlight
and let me
well three-dimensional printing physical
things are going to be transformed to I
think we're kind of in the hype phase
now 3d printing that's going to take off
in the 2020s when we have submicron
resolutions what we ultimately will
greatly expand our ability to create
physical things as an information
technology and ultimately computerize
devices will be the size of blood cells
we will put them in our bloodstream
they'll augment our immune system
they'll provide virtual reality from
within the nervous system and they'll
also provide a direct connection from
our brain to outside the brain to the
cloud
that sounds very futuristic I'd point
out that Parkinson's patients already
have a neural implant a computer
connected into their brain that connects
outside the patient they can download
new software to this neural implant from
outside the patient so I've been
thinking about thinking for 50 years and
we have now effective models of how it
works the spatial resolution of
non-invasive brain scanning is doubling
every year we have effective models now
functional models of the neocortex which
is where we do our thinking that's the
outer layer of the brain emerge 200
million years ago with mammals it's a
picture of it right there on the top and
we don't have perfect knowledge but
we're gaining actually very useful
information from the brain reverse
engineering projects here in Europe in
the United States that are giving us
hints as to how the neocortex works what
would what I'm doing in my group at
Google is actually creating simulations
functional simulations of how we believe
the neocortex works those will get more
refined as we learn more and more about
the brain and I'll just give you a
simple example
there the basic function of the
neocortex a basic unit is not one neuron
we've made great advances as you may
have heard in deep neural nets where we
can now actually go multiple layers and
get very abstract features just a few
years ago people's challenge was well AI
can't even tell the difference between a
dog and a cat now we can and 10,000
other categories as well with these deep
neural nets but they're the chief unit
that we're building on as a neuron the
real way the brain is organizes in
modules of about a hundred neurons and
each of these modules can recognize a
pattern and we were debating at dinner
last night exactly which mathematical
model fit that best hidden Markov model
or a long short temporal memory I won't
elaborate on that right now but we're
gaining more and more insight as to how
these work and they're organized in
hierarchies as you go up the hierarchy
we recognize even more and more abstract
features at the very highest level about
15 20 levels high we recognize things
like oh that was funny that was ironic
she's pretty you might think that those
are more sophisticated it's actually the
hierarchy below them that's more
sophisticated
the sixteen-year-old girl was having
brain surgery she was talking to the
surgeons they wanted to talk to her you
can do that because there's no pain
receptors in the brain whenever they
stimulated these points on her read she
would start to laugh and they thought
that there was they had found some kind
of laugh reflex but no they had actually
found the points in her neocortex that
recognized humor whenever they
stimulated these points she would start
to laugh you guys are so funny just
standing there was a comment and they
weren't funny not while doing brain
surgery but we're gaining more and more
insight and this is helping us to build
artificial intelligence ultimately we
will use artificial intelligence first
of all to recognize language the head of
Watson this here will tell you about his
system we're creating something similar
Google which can actually understand
language Watson got this query correct
in the rhyme category a long tiresome
speech delivered by a frothy pie topping
and it quickly said what is a meringue
Harang which is pretty good the humans
didn't get that it got a higher score
than the best of humans combined and it
got its knowledge by reading Wikipedia
and we're doing something similar at
Google ultimately we will put AI in the
cloud will connect with these nanobots
to extra neocortex in the cloud you know
if I want to this is very powerful but
if I want to do anything interesting
like a search or language translation
doesn't take place in this device this
can multiply itself thousands or
millions fold by connecting wirelessly
to the cloud we ultimately will do that
with these nano robots in our brain so
if I'm walking along and I see somebody
says oh but think of something clever
I've got two seconds my 300 million near
cortical modules isn't gonna cut it
I need a billion or ten billion for two
seconds I'll be able to access that
wirelessly in the cloud just the way
these devices can access additional
computation in the cloud and so will
become a hybrid of biological and
non-biological thinking and we'll apply
that to solving the problems of humanity
will introduce some new problems along
the way we'll talk about promise and
peril
little bit later this morning thank you
very much
you